hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
we're going into this new area here that
I don't entirely know and someone by the
name of Norton with his antivirus did
done steal all of our goodie goodies now
I know there's more stuff to do in that
middle section and we're gonna get to
that very soon if there is cool stuff to
do I got your ambushed by cow who's
hiding behind a billboard a big
billboard big cow that's a reference I
don't know my god my eyes Gary you need
a lot more powder inside of you
well Gary ain't gonna do me no good
until it gets buffed up maybe I should
have chosen a different idiom I can see
now how that might have been confusing I
had no idea what you were talking about
from the get-go so I have no idea
putrid cow bile why would I drink that
this is a little vial of rancid cow bile
that you kept for some reason yeah you
got that right
no idea why but we're going over the
last custard stand sir I can't see a cut
tempting well howdy there welcome to the
last custard stand
I'm custard man Stan and I make custard
like only tested men Stan can care to
try some tell me about your custard Stan
custard Stan man Stan not much to tell
just to play an honest custard stand
selling plain honest custody but it's
the last one but like the last one
before you get to Frisco er last one in
the whole territory heck the last one in
the whole world so far as I know but I
can't swear to that are you sure it
isn't the first yep because the first
was also mine it was farther up north
whole dang operation was ate by wasps
standing all give me them sweet custards
ah why do I want these sweet custards
nope I'm not gonna blow my money on
those sweet custards because I've got to
find something isn't there there's an
old Medicine Show over here maybe they
know something but there's also oh no I
can't get back to that town for the
doctor they'd probably be able to help
me mr. glyphs my fifth is the fifth of
the burning I closing okay thank you
very much for that
know what that means hello what are you
doing Gary Oh No
Goering is hearing ass me saying
antivirus this terrible for real
everything looks really weird and it's
making me dizzy Goblin doctors are using
honey to curing a lot of bed sickness
may be needing a honey of power where do
we find that
Oh Roy being special honey jellybeans
having that's one hell of a coincidence
but it's worth a shot
let's get going okay I don't need to be
here Roy being over in Roy beans house
has obscure to this goddamn ailment dear
my antivirus my eyes are hurting me and
everybody at home obviously
howdy muffler you just scary you just
said Jess Jerry does this jelly bean
really cost us 6000 meters beyond e
jelly bean Oh Oh well normally it does
yeah Gary seeing as how you help me out
with them bandits and goblins but damn
dirty hippies let's call her five five
meet really yeah I reckon better buy in
a hurry for us changed my mind okay I'll
buy it you hand over the meat you almost
feel bad because of the depths of the
discount but I'm gonna eat this
instantaneously because I can't stand
this blood you need the jellybeans in
your vision clean mmediately clears
modern medicine is really amazing when
you get medicine in the form of jelly
beans which is awfully wonderful I think
anyway where are we going now is we got
to go back to Frisco and then wander
around it some the desolate lonesome
coast fort unnecessary
right I'll go to Ford unnecessary I
don't know why Ford unnecessary is there
or why it's unnecessary in the first
place but we'll see
hello sad looking for it it's kind of in
disrepair yeah the soldiers here must
not be very good at their jobs
instructing soldiers to cheering up a
fort okay all right well all right then
see you around somebody arraigns these
cannons haphazardly and left them out in
the rain a harried looking woman looked
in a military outfit darts in front of
the doors you enter whoo no I can't
believe it I can't be having any more
misfits in this jerkwad you can either
swear to me that you're half way
competent heck even a quarter and that
you'll help out this sort of crew of
no-hoper so you can turn right back in
March double-time okay all right I'm
gonna hold you to that promise come on
in I'm captain Harriet Davenport my name
is mom Fleur bumper dink was the problem
cap problems yeah welcome to camp fubar
where are all the Army's idiots breach
extra cent so they're out of my way I
have to get up to my eyeballs trying to
run this place
please help these morons figure out
their mouth functions so they can get
the muster out here and leave me in
peace you give me some details whoa boy
he'll need to talk to them individually
for more information but the brief is
you got a scout who's blind as a bat who
can't figure out it make corned beef on
ass on toast
God can't load in fire cannon without
blowing up someone or maybe shooting it
backwards a guy who somehow and I can't
for the life of me figure it out it's
too bowlegged to ride a horse and a kid
who was sent here because he can't
figure out a tie bow tie well just get
putting icing on the cake we have an
infinite goblins living in this storage
shed
Wow okay I begin to see the scope of
your complaint how you are not just
whistling Dixie so what have you been
get to do send here you hear hear teeth
grinding is he growls at you do you not
ask okay well then I'll just take a look
around
sky squints real hard as you approach
howdy do I know you your fuzzy
silhouette doesn't seem familiar
nope I'm passing through what are you
doing here huh I'm supposed to be a
scout oh I broke my only pair of glasses
without him I can't see a dang thing try
to get you a new pair I'd be much
obliged I hear there's a jeweler or not
too far from here he probably could grab
me a pair of lenses just tell them to
make him think
Dickens I don't wanna know why why it's
thick as the Dickens a Dickens or the
Dickens no matter what I don't like it
okay but I'll do that eventually
yes petunia near dammit it's too much
sass core
I got a medal of this medal was awarded
to general fire Francoise what's his
name for his holy undistinguished
service goes on your lapel that's damn
good for being holy undistinguished that
is a damn good medal of adequacy hey
when you couldn't tell your friends
about marklar you tell me boy that lets
players adequate whatever he done do is
pretty much good enough for anything
that I would want in my viewing pleasure
whatever okay howdy what's wrong
Oh let's eat Wilkers I had a pretty good
job it's the generals personal assistant
but I got fired and reassign here what
happened was great at first and pretty
good at scheduling and I can break
through her in an A+ boot polisher but
then the general winning decided to look
more serious and sophisticated with a
bowtie he's supposed to be to do the
time for him no good no I could do a
cheap ragged bold lie to the clover inch
but with laser me I can't get a bowtie
to look right sterile slippery out here
but breakfast I got to go back to a turd
or I'll help you out
listen grab the two hands like this you
a little shorter you grab the other end
you tie wrap around lasso butter around
your torso like that snip snap it up the
zigzag side put the strainer up bit down
over and bend over and kiss your ass
good-bye and then fold it under there
and then hold tight
dad if you go back and forth a few times
until it gets right without poking
themself in the eye
I think if God thanks why wait I'll show
the Gerald alright see ya I guess you
shoot yourself awake hey a stranger how
you doing over there looking pretty good
it would be cruel to learn these
people's supplies
howdy private cooker oh how appropriate
well would be if I knew how to cook like
a little bit seems to be the trouble we
only got two ingredients here I cannot
for the life of me figure out how to
combine them what are the ingredients
corn beef hash and toast try to help him
with a metaphor what have you thought
this to toast what have you thought of
the toast as your elbow he not seeming
to understand where you're going with it
and think of the corned beef as your
head so I should put the corned beef
hash underneath no next sorry don't get
can we try Thank You Josie is your elbow
corned beef is hole in the ground
Ashu corned beef is corncob pipe well
goddamn it okay think of the choice as a
road map and corned beef is shinola okay
hurry you're not getting this okay
think of the toast as your elbow again
I'm corned beefs corncob pipe you put it
on your elbow licky spitting ain't got
it makes sense no okay all right think
of the choice as shingle he put your
head in the shingle with the corned beef
you ain't no eat corned beef with no
head on you're single bow you ain't
gotta get that no I didn't put that
right think of think of a shingle on
your head
think of it as a road map leading you to
shinola how about you take your shoe and
you put it on your head
nope okay alright well how about you
take your elbow and you take it all the
way to shinola oh i shouid shinola
what's shinola why is this you know mix
you know I don't even know what shinola
is or where it is or what it is
it is alright whatever all in the day's
work I I guess
okay well got that done I suppose good
for me hi well hello
this horse has four left sure it does
howdy they called me private bow legs I
can see why you seem uncomfortable you
ain't kidding look at my legs they're
bent so fine I can hardly touch both
knees at once walking hurts like a
Dickens then you did can you tell me how
big is a Dickens I'm not asking a
personal question I need to know the
captain said it keeps you from riding a
horse yep they're too wide horse slips
right right out a tween huh
think I could ride a mule though what
with them being a tad lower to the
ground the better legs
excuse me I got some strong squeezers
here just bite down on something don't
scream oh honey um Hill this is fixable
well ok with some group
with some grunts from you some cries of
pain from him
you normalize his life oh great jumpin
jiminy man oh don't be a baby look
they're much straighter now I guess I
can't not that he winces as he mounts
the nearby oars and rides out of camp
[Laughter]
hey what's the haps I'm supposed to be a
can of New Year I'm they're all gonna
have the same voice well I'm terrible at
loading cannons they always explode
expect not the way they're supposed to
explode for us they don't explode at all
huh the only time I ever going to fire
right can't ball knocked my sergeants
hat off are you standing behind me sue
can't figure out how that happened
so they assign me to this loser squad
and said I can't report back for a
proper duty that's your I figure out
although the cannon tried give them the
book I remember I got canned and loaded
for idiots earlier here maybe this will
oh well let's see you flipped through
the pages which is a big number diagrams
oh you take the stick back out before
you put the cam ball in well I certainly
sounds easier they did not have the same
voice all right he carefully follows
along the directions in the book and
successfully fires a cannonball over the
wall the fort I'll do it Wow great
thanks a lot I will get mine go get my
new assignments right away cool good
luck guy
congratulations good job sign in front
says important gun storage no goblins
you open the door and crack take a peek
naturally the ship is full of couplings
to the ceiling they're barely
recognizable as individual goblins Wow
geez Paul what let Gary seeing Gary
takes a peek in reels back in shock
slamming the door Oh gross awful a
goblin
popping in there maybe two then what
happened
all those spores and know where to going
oh growing into new goblins and they
just smooshing all up probably better
not mess with that it might explode
well that is something I am NOT gonna
deal with how did cap
howdy bird Inc you're doing great
job out there looks like only one
hapless goofball left to fix
oh yeah the glasses guy okay our I'm
gonna find that jeweler's cabin over
there no one's gonna get in my way on
the way they're right over I burrito aw
don't have a buttery jewelry shop inside
that seems untrustworthy all Gary is
hearing about this a goblin
jewelry-making
you really yes a famous goblin artisan
Nam intrigued oh hello
oh hello a customer why hello welcome to
master gerald jewelry shop how do you
are you master Gerald oh no master
Gerald was back there at his workbench
I'm just as her system and translator a
goblin jewel Smith you bet in your
britches sunny oh you petting your
britches sunny and not forgetting it
he says that's right the finest jewelry
in the territory well what do you know I
don't see anything on display though
master Gerald only does bespoke work if
you bring him in in sufficiently
valuable gemstone he'll craft it into a
fine ring for you for a fee good thing I
didn't show my Spinks tone oh good thing
I just took my pants off good thing I
didn't do that no trash rocks I need a
pair of eyeglasses huh having some old
soda bottles for grinding down should
working fine he says yes we have some
glass of the finest optical qualities I
remember me maybe later
master Gerald takes a look at the rocks
you have with you my effluvia semer old
woo sets it in a fine ring for you but
all of trash and garbage being the ring
that is that this is the most similar to
the ring around the waterline of a
filthy toilet hilarious and I paid 500
meet to get this rig great thanks anyway
though alright how about you do the
glasses thing
sure clerk invites you to the back to
have a seat in the living area while
master Gerald works to cutting and
grinding some glass and lenses and
setting them into wireframes you flip
through a gaba magazine while you wait
the lead article seems to be about
social interaction with humans and the
value of occasionally pretending to be
dumber than you actually are
okay close enough for government working
master Gerald is completed your
spectacles with the utmost degree of
craftsmanship very thick spectacles here
you are well that cost me five hundred
goddamn goddamn meets your eyebrows are
getting kind of wild looking that's
better
this must be the assistance toilet it
doesn't have any rough rusty scrap metal
bolted on to be a goblin toilet yay all
right goblin bed maybe hmm there a
dining table but they left out a stack
of magazine for customers to look at
while the waiting they're all in goblin
though most of them are goblin celebrity
gossip and crossword puzzles have
already been filled in okay all right
see you bye-bye bye okay we got what we
needed all right so we can go back to
for it unnecessary now and hopefully
this is unnecessary adventure with a
Belcher fifthly flaps or whoa okay all
right bang go get him Gary Gary that's
not getting him you're about to be
smooshed
yep dick you got smooshed Gary sorry
about that didn't mean for that to
happen but it happened nonetheless
all right back for it unnecessary what
do we got going on over hello I've got
some very thick spectacles he takes the
glasses and puts him on and looks around
well I'll be never realize what a dump
this place is climbs atop of the
watchtower and peers over the
countryside it work I can see a dang
thing hooray great cool all right I did
it great job
everyone's dealt with an out of here and
that means I'm finally out of this
hellhole do we ever cross paths again I
really owe you one
frisbees our clipboard snaps you a
salute and marches out of the fort oh
well lookee lookee me
looki looking me and how goody-goody I
am ha abandoned mine you say I'll check
it out whoo
then well this seems interesting
anything over here there's a shiny thing
in here
whoaaa strange silvery crystals silver
silver colored not silver coated in the
sense that it's made I can take that to
the jeweler probably maybe I don't know
I'm just guessing but uh hello can you
lose some up can you align it with a
wrench can I ride it down to this bandit
mine that's probably gonna get me killed
probably I mean if I just had to wear
venture a guess on everything killing me
out here it's probably gonna give me a
kill get give me a it's gonna it's gonna
kill me somethin's cures poisoning by
making vomit but luckily medical science
had confirmed that vomiting is secured
to basically every type of poisoning
great gross blood building tonic it's
bad medicine promises to increase your
volume the volume and viscosity of your
blood each the switches long since
rusted away to uselessness so we got a
lot of useless here all right
whoa what's up with these weird rocks oh
I got teleported okay makuu stewpot
jalopy facility okay
Oh punch cards cool I need those all
right cylinder okay well I don't have a
key stone but close all right then
there's gotta be something in these
caverns right
no nothing over there gonna meet vane
yes
oh hell yeah oh yeah whoa well that's
probably bad mining gear dynamite and
all the goodies stuff okay well this
looks bad whew cult is camp good for me
let's see and now it says dear Jeff got
called up north to deepest delve see you
soon praise be Roberto sincerely jewel
all right then sarsaparilla come
nighttime SAS parallel RL are all right
well okay there's some point of this
long since rusted away to uselessness
not that it was valid a useful before
giving the track layout
oh nice Thanks how are you doing I got
the Jumbo who you guys look tough
bang welp didn't think about that one
bang okay good all right you got some
good skins off of them but what were
they hiding
Mitch Mitch so much meat oh my god it
was that only thing that was in this
mine and was that it Oh goof me goof me
hard right past a woman who's running
along the desert trail on foot although
I'd say running it's a slow run with a
novel open gate de-stress oddly - no hat
just a thin strip of fabric died across
her forehead like clothing and strange
soft looking boots that barely even come
up through ankles everything all right
are you running away from something
something pretty slow like maybe a
desert tortoise no not out on no talking
but talking and Ben it is like slow
running well where I'm from we just walk
it's better exercise if you go faster
I'm fast enough to actually get away for
anything though a full outrunning wears
you out that isn't as healthy so theour
than being eaten by a bear I look I'm
not being chased by beard I've never
been chased by a bear yes it's obvious
you're alive and not mangled lumps it's
about physical fitness bears aren't an
issue okay you're right thank you
all right many bears out here in the
desert
a coyote so you'd be in real trouble it
was a very frustrating conversation it
tear you to shreds even without those
goofy-looking shoes matches I need
myself goofy they're pretty goofy I mean
what good are they began even run
properly in them they don't prevent they
certainly are gonna protect your ankles
from coyote bites
I'll be perfectly good for kicking your
ass gosh all this exercise has made you
kind of belligerent get down off that
horse how about we see if you can catch
me right away the jogger runs after you
for a bit yelling but as predicted you
can't catch you gotta be yep alright
good good encounter good encounter well
hello there you got to get that train
back this is embarrassing Smee points to
that set of deep ruts off to the side of
the railroad track no one's taking the
train oh oh I see what I need to do
follow the tracks you jump on Templars
black and ride like the wind following
the railroad tracks back into the desert
when you finally catch up you stand up
on Tim Fleur saddle and leap onto the
back of the Train like a real badass
just barely catching the edge of the
roof and pulling yourself up here's
hoping you don't have to do that again
your stuntman could have been killed
looks like Gary decided not to join you
on account of not having a stuntman so
you're on your own until you get back to
Frisco oh oh all right then
hello oh you're feeling neither fair nor
square take the train back by force I'll
be back I'll be back excuse me labels
hand fruit pickled fig pickled pig
knuckles I'm not even gonna try that
someone carefully stacked these with
this end up arrows all pointing in
different directions
alright good for me this barrels
labelled pickled crackers alright
barrel is labeled nubs alright oh can I
get safecracking
gonna get it I got a lot of XP um just
enough oh cargo car key ok so key to the
car of the drain should have said key
instead of keys ok I get it whoo it's
the door to the next car it's locked
with an unpickable plot brand lock
unlock it you hear Norton scurrying
forward on the roof okay
whoa hi hello who are you
why are you here I didn't guys look
angry and confused
oh saying I'll be right back
whoa all right then whoa well then oh
these guys are so preoccupied with the
door to the rear of the car they don't
notice you prowling around behind them
when in the back is a shiny key attached
to his belt it must be to keep you the
dining car because it is dining car
stamped into it with big letters big
enough to read from ear I got a lot of
moxie I'm gonna grab them boink burglar
has become the Burghley okay unlock okay
nice flowers it's got one of those fancy
silver dumb things investigate huh
you never wanted anything more in your
life then don't lift up this dome and
see what's under it but you're not sure
you can muster the amount of culinary
expertise it requires to properly reveal
a dish of such presumed quality I'm
gonna do it voila oh it's his cream pie
shaving cream lunatics are running the
food service on this train are the
clowns are they clowns they might be
clowns seems like something clowns would
do mmm welded shut over there what's
going on up here oh yeah what's going on
there's Norton wait what you've got a
clear shot at him from here if you want
to throw that pie Adam yeah all right oh
yeah whoosh thank you all right wise guy
hanging on the top a movie train with a
knife I don't know but I'm not gonna
find out I would have got here maybe you
better read the note on the wall first
I'm trying to ah there we go
the note says I've hidden the key to the
Ford passenger car and my luggage to
make it easier for me to murder
everybody in the sleeper car sincerely
the trained murderer come to the roof of
the sleeper car in the next 55 minutes
if you want a murder and crazy okay all
right then so when a sleeping
compartments must belong to the murderer
maybe it's the first one you open the
door or sole occupant is little boy
about ten years old wearing blue suiting
knickerbockers oh uh hello sir is
something wrong nothing you need to
worry about kid I'm on the trail of a
bad guy
you mean a murderer sir I'm pretty sure
there's one on this train and they don't
call me the world's greatest detective
for nothing
what's your name kid I probably got to
say sir there might be a copyright thing
okay well I'm pretty sure I can handle
this just let me ask you one question
then you should lock the door after I'm
gone I understand sir what would you
like to know
are you on the roof of the Train excuse
me the murderer left a note saying is on
the roof of the train are you
I know sir I'm it I'm in my passenger
compartment good that'll be all thank
you
all so what's this there's nothing
without knowing which piece of luggage I
got you
hello excuse him Wow is there somewhere
I might be of us this dance miss well
don't you miss you sorry to bother you
but there's a murderer on the loose and
I'm checking the passenger compartments
sacrebleu
this is very serious more than me allow
me to bother do you the use of my little
language you're speaking it's not a very
good convincing ask accent that to be
sure let me ask you this one question
why Shelton Yee I am at your service are
you on the roof of the drain
roof of the Train Monsieur right now
that's right oh I'm here conversing with
you all right thank you you up the door
a third passenger compartment and find
nobody inside hmm since the note of the
murderer said he was gonna be on the
roof of the train that could mean he
couldn't begin this passenger
compartment and since there's no one
inside the passenger compartment whoever
the commandant belongs to can only by
process of elimination be on the roof
which means the person who rented this
compartment must be the murderer
probably the only clue you find in here
is a luggage ticket though and has the
number three on it all right the only
passenger in this compartment is a
middle-aged woman who was reading
something in a notebook she looks up as
you enter greets you with a friendly
northeastern accent why hello is there
something you need dear I don't know
what a northeastern accent it so I'm
gonna go with this sorry to bother you
ma'am
and I don't want to alarm you but
there's a murderer on board the train
and I'm investigating a murder on the
train my goodness that would be a
wonderful Bremen's for my next novel
sure why not anyway I just need to ask
you a question go ahead a dear according
my evidence the murderer is on the roof
of the train are you on the
the dream no no dear alright thank you
for your time would you like a meat pie
they're all made no thanks just have a
look at this playing card before you go
goodbye now I appreciate the lady here
isn't the murderer robbed probably oh
you find back number three and has a key
to the passenger car inside a very
strong corroborating evidence for your
theory of who the murderer is
hmm I don't it deduce this real good
like rise farewell oh you finally make
it to the passenger car one car back
from the locomotive which may be
confusing if you thought locomotive
meant the entire train so I could just
say the engine except that also reserves
to the engine itself that is the actual
steam engine that makes a train go and
not just the front of the car of the
train anyway here in the passenger car
suddenly Norton clambers in the window
he must have dramatically clung to the
side of the train in order to reveal at
the last minute that he actually hadn't
been defeated dang it he runs into the
well frontmost car at the train and
locks the door jerk maybe you could some
of the rest of the passengers to help
you break down the door and arrest him
maybe you could just kick that door down
and shoot him until he can't bother
anybody anymore up to you well alright
then it's profess oriole looking guys
frowning and an actual sheet of paper
and occasionally scribbles down on a
pencil and then erasing what he just
wrote excuse me can you help me with
something
sorry I'm busy that's my wife or my
daughter God now she could do with
something to keep her occupied what are
you working on it's quite academic I'm
sure you wouldn't understand
you must know I'm a scholar of foreign
antiquities I'm attempting to resolve
this ancient conundrum for the Far East
he shows you a sheet of paper covered
with little boxes some of which have
numbers in them I'll solve it for you
that's a Sudoku my little brother thinks
are for babies what look this box can't
be a3 blah blah blah filling the rest of
the puzzle well damn it what fun is that
if you just shove it for me sorry will
you help me break down the door to the
engine arrest the Emperor I guess I got
nothing better to do
alright cool then this woman just
ignores you guys totally pram ticking
which means which is a word I made up
that means ranting in a frantic panic
everything everyone else is ignoring him
as hard as they can
hey buddy you okay it's a lie we're
never gonna get to Frisco brisket ball
probably doesn't even exist they've been
testing to see how long we got
table married minutes and Bob water now
they're driving us on to the country to
say I've got a government camp they're
gonna use our organs as fuel for alien
flying machines Wow I don't know what
percussive maintenance is slap him
requires percussive maintenance love
that but I don't have that unfortunately
right what do you got
this woman is focusing on her knitting
and ignoring the general commotion she
must have been knitting the whole trip
because of the scarf she's made could
accommodate a whole marching band talk
to her excuse me ma'am whatever it is I
want no part of it I keep myself to
myself and have no desire to get
involved thank you very much I mean
everything will sort itself out in the
end and in the meantime I have plenty of
wool can I level up my horn swagman ah
no I need a little more oh damn it okay
fine then little girls peering out the
window clearly bored hi they're busy no
all my toys and Friends are in our
luggage and it's boring and I hate it
do you want to help me out with
something really important huh like what
well a bad guy took over the engine car
and I need some people to help break
down the door and arrest him what mr.
rap just a little girl hey now that's
not a good attitude don't ever let
everyone then even to tell you candy
don't don't don't don't let anyone tell
you known you no can do no all right
yeah well Plus that crooks face in
that's the spirit you got to pay me
advance
jeez you're learning a little too fast
all right what do you want I like
stuffed animals right back all right can
you make a stuffed animal can you make
it alright fine then juice all right
flipping through a book that'll birds of
the western territory since most of the
places desert isn't very long book
excuse me ma'am
yes a crazy psycho was taken over the
train set in car and I need volunteers
to help break down the door and arrest
him oh my I certainly couldn't be of any
help I'm very conflict diverse what if I
told you he hates Birds and is
determined to outlaw them from the
territory after he sees his power
it's very sly but I know you're only
saying that because you saw the book
how's me
yeah you got me there any other ideas to
convince me suddenly you hear a tapping
and tapping at the passenger window
what the Russell Russell you open the
window and your pet crow Russell flaps
and it perches on your shoulder hey
buddy good to see ya
CAW oh my gosh what a beautiful crow and
he knows you well sure me and Russell go
way back right buddy
CAW I rescued him from a cat when he was
only just out of the nest and raised him
as a pet I set him free when I left home
recently what's he doing here
has he been following you since then no
I probably just happened to be flying by
and spy me off the roof of the train to
recognize me girls are crazy smart like
that that's amazing Oh what I wouldn't
give to have an Etienne friend like that
well I'm still gonna be doing a lot of
traveling after this I figure so I can't
really drag Russell along with me uh-huh
I bet Russell wouldn't mind being pals
with a nice lady in Frisco to help save
the Train what do you think Russ cool
flaps overs perched next to the lady my
goodness how could I refuse it's a
pleasure to meet you Russell my name's
Annabel awesome I'll let you know when
ready okay but there's a problem
Oh overweight man in three-piece suit
bowler hat is probably a banker or
something cuz eyes are closed and his
posture is relaxed but the clench of his
jaw but raises aggravation I excuse me
erm what is it crazy jerk calling
himself the Emperor Norton has hijacked
the Train and I need volunteers to help
me bust down the door and arrest him I
see
I'd rather not that sounds quite
strenuous brats even dangerous Wow
please no I don't think so I'm quite
comfortable here and I prefer Dewey
Dewey tris please again no I'm supposed
to avoid things that might raise my
blood pressure believe sugar on top
sure is one of those things pretty
please with baby on top rabies and other
places leave me alone please I said no
stop asking please leave please I'll
stop asking if you say yes please all
right God fine I'll just leave me alone
I don't have everybody hmm how to deal
with this I don't think I can leave ah
[Music]